I read a bunch of interviews that you've
done in the past always referencing
dangerous things you do and that's thing
and then I remembered that one of the
last times that you were on one of my
shows you this road
we rode like crazy that's real cars
raced Jimmie Johnson yes and so I
realized the neck and neck yes and it
was you want did you winner
I believe I always win but here's the
crazy thing is that I realize like not a
lot of guests do that you seem like kind
of a daredevil and then I hear this
rumor and all if it's true that you
jumped out of an airplane with a
parachute thank God yeah and that you
and this is down in Florida and that you
drifted into Cuban airspace right is
there any truth to this none whatsoever
no I be some truth to it they don't just
make up complete lies I always take some
truth and then okay something too yes
well the truth part is that I did walk
by a place where you could skyguy I was
on us one I was driving by and there was
a place where you could go skydiving I
will look skydiving and then I kept
going so that's really the only I never
even went skydiving
I know no that's not true I did go
skydiving I went up in the plane
of course I do wait a minute now I
honestly don't know this what anything
for good reason why I don't understand
don't you go skydiving
there was a time when what is going well
I did go skydiving yes sir let's start
again if you are Christian Slater are
you not are you Christian Slater let me
think
oh okay yes I did go skydiving but as
far as doing the Cuban airspace thing I
was in Key West
I was 90 miles outside of Cuba of course
because the southernmost point I think
it's about 99 it's 90 miles so my
parachute did start to drift and head
into some Cuban airspace and then as I
was falling down there was a pool of
sharks as well that I was heading
towards and all of these boats started
to circle us and aim these phenomenal
rifles up at my and so one guy took a
shot at my parachute and blew a hole in
the thing and I started to plummet very
very quickly to the earth headed right
towards these sharks whatever did you do
well fortunately Cindy Crawford was
there
[Laughter]
[Applause]